dos feminicidios de similares
características se vuelven a Elevar la
alerta sobre la falta de seguridad de
las mujeres frente a la violencia de
género en medio oriente y el norte de
África por un lado nayera asraf una
joven egipcia de 21 años se fue
asesinada el lunes pasado entras en
rechazar la propuesta de matrimonio de
un compañero que se presentó en las
puertas de la Universidad de manzura y
la mató a cuchillazos la mujer había
denunciado en el pasado el acoso
permanente de su agresor Mohamed Adele
quien este domingo en el inicio del
juicio confesó su culpabilidad y se
enfrenta a una posible pena de muerte 13
días después de este hecho imán reside
una joven jordana también de 21 años Fue
asesinada de un disparo en la cabeza en
las inmediaciones de la Universidad de
amán tras negarse a hablar con un hombre
de 37 años el atacante identificado como
oday Janet abdulada hassan murió este
lunes entre dispararse en la cabeza para
evitar ser arrestado por la policía que
lo tenía rodeado estos dos hechos sobre
sumados a otras dos muertes de mujeres
en circunstancias todavía por esclarecer
en emiratos árabes Unidos y sus Jordania
despertaron una ola de indignación y de
ira en una región donde la violencia el
acoso y la misoginia contra las mujeres
son monedas corriente como respuesta a
través de las redes sociales se ha
lanzado una convocatoria a un paro
Regional de mujeres el próximo 6 de
Julio la idea de esta campaña es que las
mujeres en medio oriente y en el norte
de África
ese día eviten ir a sus trabajos entre
más tarde eviten realizar tareas del
hogar o cualquier otra manifestación que
les permita alzar la voz frente a la
violencia de género